miranda devine is a columnist for the
new york post and a fox news contributor
miranda what is happening over there
it's not pretty
no it's not and you're absolutely right
um their whole business model was based
on hating donald trump trump derangement
syndrome and without donald trump to
kick around anymore they really don't
have anything else especially in prime
time all their opinion hosts they're
just sort of living on the fumes of the
trump era and i think they're all
praying like hell that donald trump will
come back in 2024 even though they
pretend that that's the worst thing in
the world
it's what they need to kick-start their
ratings yeah they're two hosts in prime
time accused of sexual assault none of
them can crack over a million
all day at any hour and you're right
i've heard from the inside that not only
cnn but all of these mainstream legacy
reporters are dying for trump to run
again because that's all they have
it's all they have they have
cnn was supposed to be the 24 7 news
channel they've given that up for
24 7 propaganda and as you said so aptly
they have lied to their viewers and i
think their ratings are tied to joe
biden's plummeting poll ratings because
they were all in on joe biden on
mythologizing him as this unifying
president who was a moderate and as
especially independents have come to
their senses and realized that in fact
that's the opposite of what joe biden is
that joe biden himself has been lying to
them just like cnn lies
they are completely disillusioned and
switching off on both the president and
cnn yeah they're watching 90 day fiance
and you're right about the business
model that was half of the business
model the other half was covering big
breaking live news events and what have
we had we've had afghanistan we've had
the delta surge we've had these very
controversial mandates and even with all
of that pretty juicy news they still
have underperformed i don't think they
know what to do
and if you look at you know those of
their hosts that have actually clung to
news breaking news and not being so
biased and not pushing propaganda as
much have actually their ratings have
survived a bit more but people like don
lemon like brian stelter the media guy
who's constantly you know rabbiting on
about how cnn people have the moral high
ground and people at fox at dreadful
even wrote a book about that he is
number 18
on the weekend viewers i mean the only
reason he's there is because he's sort
of a clone of jeff zucker he looks like
jeff zucker he loves jeff zucker he is
jeff zucker the boss's mouthpiece
otherwise would you give the guy a job
on tv no well zucker might not be there
for that much longer if this continues
and maybe brian won't either we'll see
what happens miranda thank you so much
for covering yeah they need all the help
they can get thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else